me streptococcus mutans hey my friends
call me strep he's a bacterium and a bit
of a slob it's what's on your teeth you
see strep in all his roommates live
inside your mouth feeding off of the
sugar and protein in your food when
they're done they excrete a slimy
substance all over your pearly whites
the end result is a bacteria-ridden
pigsty called biofilm now a little
biofilm isn't gonna hurt you it's only
when you stop brushing it away that
things can get ugly and not only for
your teeth it just so happens that strep
and his friends are a downright threat
to your life nearly half of Americans
don't brush their teeth enough and when
food builds up in those nooks and
crannies you're inviting a host of
bacteria to the party including your gum
line which irritate and inflame your
gums causing tenderness and bleeding but
that's just the start soon enough
that infection will trigger your immune
system which sends spider cells to
battle the bacteria this creates a
hostile environment for the bacteria
which is what you want but it can also
damage the cells in nearby tissue and
bone six months two years later that
tissue and bone will eventually die at
this point you don't have gingivitis
anymore you have something much worse
periodontal disease no more tissue and
bone means no more structural support so
your gums separate from your teeth
forming pockets that quickly become
extra space for strep and his friends
which further infects your gums causing
your teeth to fall out now
you may
think this could never happen to you but
about 10% of Americans between ages 50
to 64 have lost not one not two but all
of their teeth and to make matters worse
strep and his buddies may enter your
bloodstream where they'll wreak havoc on
your organs - for example in one study
people with periodontal disease were
four and a half times more likely to
have chronic kidney disease than people
with healthy gums and another study
found that people in a retirement
community who didn't brush their teeth
daily had up to 65 percent greater risk
of dementia last but not least there's
an increased risk of developing certain
cancers to be fair these risks can also
be the result of poor hygiene in general
but the message remains clear brush your
teeth it's worth the extra four minutes
a day
[Music]